Which of the following triangles
are similar to triangle ABC?
So let's just review
what similarity
means when we're
talking about triangles.
So let's say this
is one triangle.
And I'll assume it's
a right triangle,
although what I'm about to
say is true for any triangle.
And let's say this
is another one.
You have similar triangles if
all of the corresponding angles
are equivalent.
So that angle is
equivalent to that angle.
And I drew that
as a right angle.
Let's say that this angle
is equivalent to this angle.
And let's say that this angle
is equivalent to that angle.
Then these two
triangles are similar.
They are not
necessarily congruent.
They don't necessarily
have all of the same sides.
But they do have all
of the same angles.
And when you have all
of the same angles,
the ratios between corresponding
sides is going to be constant.
So for example, if this side
has length 2 and this side
has length 1, you
have a 2 to 1 ratio
between the second longest
side and the shortest side.
Then you're also going to
have a 2 to 1 ratio here.
So maybe this has length 3.
Then this one would be 1.5.
3 to 1.5 is the same
thing as 2 to 1.
Now, let's think
about the triangles
that they are proposing.
So the first one
is triangle CDE.
Just like triangle ABC, this is
going to be a right triangle.
How do I know?
Well, side CB is
perfectly horizontal,
and side AB is perfectly
vertical-- same thing.
Side DE is perfectly
horizontal, and side CE
is perfectly vertical.
Now, you might realize that
you have the same line acting
as a hypotenuse of both
of these triangles.
So you have the same
line right over here.
And if we wanted to prove that
the corresponding angles are
equivalent, we just
have to break out
a little bit of our geometry.
We see that we have
these two vertical lines.
So CE, this line segment
CE, you could view it
as part of a larger line
that goes like this.
It is parallel to AB.
So if you view these
as two parallel lines--
so that is parallel
to this-- and you
have a transversal
right over here,
then corresponding angles
are going to be equivalent.
So this angle right
over here is going
to be equivalent to that
angle right over there.
Similarly-- I have trouble
saying that word-- segment
DE right over here
is parallel to BC.
And so if you, once again,
look at the blue line
as a transversal,
this angle is going
to be equivalent to that angle.
So all of their corresponding
angles are equivalent.
So these are definitely
similar triangles.
Now, I went through that
fairly long-winded geometry
way of thinking about it.
But there's an easier
way to think about it.
Any time you have a line and
you construct a right angle,
where the base of
the right triangle
is essentially your change in
x between these two points.
So if you think about going
from point C to point A.
And if you first just want to
have a change in x-- so this
is our change in x right
over there-- and then
you have a change in y-- so
this is our change in y--
you're going to construct
a right triangle.
And the ratio between
these two sides
is always going to be the same.
So delta y, the change in
y, this triangle-- this
is the Greek letter
delta, just a shorthand
for saying change in y-- which
is the length of this side,
over your change in x is
always going to be constant
when you're dealing with a line.
So any triangle that's
constructed this way
from this line, the ratio
between the corresponding sides
are going to be equivalent.
And they're going to
be similar triangles.
So that would have
been an easier way
to think about this
right over here.
Now let's look at the
other options they give us.
DFG-- well, there's not really
a lot that we can say about DFG.
We're not really using the
line anymore as a hypotenuse,
so we're not going to throw
that in there as being similar.
We could actually look at
the lengths and all of that
if we wanted, but we'd
see that it's not similar.
CDG-- let me clean
this up a little bit.
CDG I'll do in-- let's
see, I've already
used-- I'll do it in blue.
So CDG-- this is not
a right triangle.
This isn't just a change
in x right over here.
This isn't a horizontal line.
And this one right over
here is not a vertical line.
So once again, this
is not similar.
In fact, this is not
even a right triangle.
So we'll mark both of these out.
And then they say ADF.
Well, once again, ADF, it's a
right triangle between D and F.
It's your change in x going
from D-- so D is at negative 2.
A is at 3.
This right over here
is your change in x.
You literally had to go 5.
This length right
over here is 5.
And then this right over
here is now vertical line.
This is a right triangle.
This is your change in y.
And these two ratios
are always going
to be constant when your
hypotenuse is a line.
So once again, this is just
one of those classic right
triangles constructed
from the line where
the base is the change in x.
This height is the change in y.
The hypotenuse is
the line itself.
These are going to be similar.
So this is definitely
a similar triangle.
And now let's actually
input it, just to make sure
that we got the right answer.
So I'm saying that and that are
similar triangles to triangle
ABC.